INTRODUCTION: The
following content
is provided by MIT
OpenCourseWare under a Creative
Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at OCW.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Ready for today's
discussion, which
I'm quite sort of happy about.
I hadn't really
seen this coming.
First, we haven't said
anything about how
do you estimate the
error in a problem.
Because we're often taking a
continuous problem coming from
a differential equation,
typically, and discretizing it,
and solving it -- solving
the discrete problem.
And we want some idea.
It's not just some math
question of course,
because, you know, in
engineering design or analysis,
an idea of what the
error is critical.
And secondly, it
gives us an idea
of where we can improve it.
You know, if we see what's
controlling the error then
we know what's going on.
So I'm speaking now about
steady-state problems.
We discussed error for
initial value problems,
and we realized there that
the error depended on --
usually finite differences.
So the error we knew
we could figure out
locally from the finite
difference that we chose.
You know, we chose second
order accurate differences
frequently, but we could've
moved up to fourth.
And then the other
ingredient you
need is stability, to know
that those local errors don't
explode as time goes forward.
OK.
So we had something to say
about error and accuracy
at that time about that topic.
And now I'm realizing that
many of our other topic
fall in this category.
And I put three of
the topics here.
In the idea sort of where the
underlying discretization is
a projection.
It's somehow a projection
between the true solution
and the discrete,
computed solution.
Somehow the discrete,
computed solution
is in some finite-dimensional
family where we can compute,
and we're projecting
into that family.
And here are three examples.
So you'll see that, actually,
what I'm talking about
is central to the
whole semester.
Well, finite elements actually
appeared more in 18.085.
So I'll have to recap
a little bit there.
But they would be
the natural tool
for solving that list
of continuous problems
from calculus of variations
that I talked about last time,
minimizing some energy, where
the energy is, typically,
an integral and we're
in the continuous case.
And what's the finite
element central idea?
It is choose these guys,
choose some basis functions,
and look at their combinations.
Maybe choose N basis functions.
I guess I better
get a chalk or it's
going to be a short lecture.
OK.
So we have a continuous
problem, continuous ODE,
ordinary differential equation
or a partial differential
equation, with boundary
conditions, as always,
that we want to make discrete.
And the point is I am
not making a discrete
by finite differences.
This is a different route
from finite differences.
And in Laplace's equation and
these, in many, many problems,
this is the preferred route.
And finite elements
are a particular choice
of these guys.
The Galerkin idea -- so I'll use
his name for the overall idea
-- is choose these, and look
for the best combination,
and we have to say
what does best mean.
Well, best is going to mean --
in our minimization problems,
it will be the combination
that gives the minimum.
The combination of
these n trial functions.
Now the exact
solution is not going
to be in that little
n-dimensional space.
Those functions
for finite elements
might be piecewise linear,
or if you want to upgrade it,
they might be
piecewise parabolas,
piecewise cubics, whatever.
That was the brilliant
finite element idea,
to choose simple functions.
And then you could
take N quite large,
but you're still not getting
the exact solution of course,
and it's to estimate
how far off you are.
But then also in multigrid,
what was the idea in multigrid?
We started with a
system at level h.
We started with some
problem A_h*u_h equal f_h,
which was a big system.
If we did ordinary
Jacobi or Gauss-Seidel,
that was too slow.
The multigrid idea
was project, there's
that magic word project,
onto to a coarse grid,
where the problem is smaller.
Here, we started with
a continuous problem,
and we got it down
to size N. Here we
start with a discrete
problem and we
cut its size in half or in
quarter or in eighth, again.
So projection is producing
a smaller problem,
and the question is
what are you losing?
And actually
conjugate gradients.
You remember these spaces?
The spaces span the
combinations of b, A*b,
A squared b and so on.
That was the computationally
convenient subspace
to project onto.
And so we've got
important examples.
Now what I realized,
I'm pleased about this,
is that they all fit.
So here's my problem,
what's the error?
So I'm going to u star
for the correct answer.
This is the true.
And I'm going to use U
star, capital U star,
for the approximate,
the one that we
get by any of those key
ideas in numerical analysis.
And I'm trying to
estimate the difference.
OK.
And I just put up
here that I'm dealing
with positive definite problems.
In fact, the matrix K, the
symmetric positive definite
problem you have, often has
this A transposed C*A form,
or in the continuous
case, K might stand for --
the A transpose might
be minus the derivative;
the C might be a
variable or constant,
the physical coefficient;
A would be d by dx,
that would be the K thing.
The equation I want
to get is K*u equal f.
That's the strong form.
Strong form will be K*u equal f.
But the whole point of
last lecture and this one
is that we don't get
to the strong form.
This projection starts
with a minimum problem,
and gets to a weak form.
And it's the minimum
problem or the weak form
that we want to think
about, not the strong form.
OK.
Now.
Up there I wrote an identity.
If you just multiply
that right hand side out,
I believe it comes out right.
And it's very valuable
for our purposes here.
OK.
So what's on the left side?
This is the quantity
that we're minimizing,
we're minimizing this.
And by just manipulation,
we wrote it this way.
So now I can identify
what u star is.
So I'm going to minimize
this over all u.
That certainly looks like
a discrete problem, right?
So think of u as a
vector, f as a vector,
K as a positive definite
symmetric matrix.
Just think about that.
But I want it to apply very
much to the continuous case
too, to differential equations.
But here's a point
then, what's the winner?
You can't immediately see --
well maybe you can, somehow,
see that when I set the
derivative of this thing to 0,
I get that equation.
You can kind of believe it, even
if it's vectors and matrices.
But here you can see
right away that --
how do I make this small?
This is a constant here.
That's just a constant,
so it doesn't depend on u.
So what choice of u
makes that term small?
Well of course it's
the choice of u
is the one that makes this
thing 0, because that's
a positive definite matrix.
No way anything is going
to get negative here.
This is a something
transposed K something.
You remember what
positive definite means.
It means that x transpose
K*x, for every vector x,
is never negative.
So the best we could
do would be to bring
this to 0, and of
course to bring it to 0
is to bring the x to 0,
to bring this thing to 0,
so this thing should be 0.
So u minus K inverse
f should be 0.
And of course, that leads us
back to the same conclusion
that we reached from
the -- the strong form.
OK.
Good.
So that an identity,
but now I want
to use this identity to answer
the question about what if I
minimize only on a subspace?
That's the problem for today.
So that's a question.
Maybe I'll write it
on this fresh board.
Now I minimize only
over some subspace.
Now can I can I use
capital U for the --
I used little u for, in here,
allowing it to be any vector,
and I found a winner.
And let me give the
winner a name, u star.
It's a real headache in
this subject of what --
just the notation.
What should we call the winner?
So sometimes I
call it u hat, that
was a familiar notation
in estimation theory,
least squares.
Today I'm going
to call it u star.
So it's u star is the
winner, small u star.
Let me take time-out, one minute
time-out, on a board -- I mean,
optimization is about the
problem of minimizing some
function F of x.
I'm just going to
take one minute
on the problems of an author.
What do you call the winning
function, winning vector,
or the winning x?
I mean it could
be just a scalar,
we could be doing just calculus.
What do I call the x
that gives the minimum?
You may have a favorite,
you can't call it x right?
I mean, because that's
just confusing it
with the variable x.
So I'm saying, well,
you could call it x hat,
you could call it x star,
you call it capital X.
So I'll just write a
few of those down --
x star would be a possibility,
x hat would be a possibility,
x minimizing would
be a possibility.
I'm doing this
just because I want
to write down the thing
that you often see,
which is argmin of F of x.
And I write that down just
so that if you ever see it,
you know what the heck it means.
It has the same meaning
as any of these.
I am not a big fan of that.
But what does this mean?
It means the argument that gives
the minimum of F of x, right.
Argument is a fancy word for
the variable in the function.
So this says the
argument that gives
the minimum of F
of x, and that's
what we're looking for to name.
But I'm sure not happy about
writing that name down.
So here it goes, it disappears.
But you'll see it, and
now you now want it means.
OK.
So this is now the
central issue here.
I want to minimize my same guy,
1/2 u transpose K*u minus u
transpose f.
Or, which is exactly the same,
that same right-hand side,
because the two are equal,
I want to minimize over some
capital U's, not all U's.
If I minimize over all U's,
then I get the exact answer.
But the idea of all
these numerical methods
is minimize over some
finite-dimensional,
smaller-dimensional,
subspace of trial functions.
I don't know.
I'll say minimize over
U in the trial space,
just to write it out in words.
OK.
Well, now I guess my name for
the winner in the trial space
is going to be U star.
So the winner in the trial
space will be U star.
So that's my finite element
solution, my conjugate gradient
solution, my multigrid solution.
All these problems are reducing
to a smaller trial space,
and picking the winner there,
computing the winner there.
And then the question of today
is how far apart are the two?
OK.
And now there's
this little formula
that gives us a good idea.
This little formula gives
us a handle on that.
So now, the point is -- So now,
can I look at this formula?
Maybe maybe I'll copy
the formula here.
This is the minimum over all
these trial guys, of 1/2 -- oh,
but I'm going to write
it that way -- 1/2 U,
that's my trial guy,
minus K inverse f,
that's my u star now.
Am I OK to give that
name to K inverse f?
Yeah, I already gave it, I
guess. u star is K inverse f.
So that's cool.
Shorter.
It's shorter and better.
K -- or its transpose -- U
minus u star plus a constant.
So I can forget that.
I can forget this constant part.
That's not important to us.
So this simple identity
then has expressed
our key discretization
approach here as finding the U,
and we're going to call it U
star, that's nearest to u star.
That's the great fact that makes
the whole subject pleasant.
OK.
So the winner U star
is then, by this,
since I'm minimizing
that expression,
it's certainly the
nearest in the K norm --
it's the nearest weighted by
K, somehow that K is important.
That K is reflecting the
problem we're solving.
That K is the energy or
whatever -- to U star.
OK.
That's the great conclusion.
You could say that's
the fundamental theorem
of this projection, error
estimates and stuff.
So do you see that
we got to that?
The thing that minimizes
makes this as small as we can.
So nearest is simply a
translation of what that says.
Pick the capital U
that's closest to u star.
OK.
Now how does that help?
That helps because I want
to estimate the difference.
So now I estimate the difference
of U star minus u star.
So I'm trying to get a handle
on how different those are.
How different is the -- so let
me take, in this case of, say,
Laplace's equation or
the 1D case -- again,
I'm speaking steady-state
boundary value problem.
So U star is the best
combination of these trial
functions, capital U, and little
u star is the exact solution.
Let me draw a picture.
So suppose I'm in 1D, 0 to 1.
OK.
Yeah, let me pick that
model problem again.
So minus the derivative
of c*du/dx is f of x.
With boundary conditions.
And I guess if I'm consistent
now, I should write u star,
because it's the
winning solution.
And suppose the boundary
conditions are 0 at both ends,
and it does something.
OK.
So that's u star.
So that's a
continuous case, which
I'm drawing a picture
to represent what
the solution might look like.
OK.
Now what about this
finite element stuff?
Suppose the phi_i's
are linear pieces.
I'm going to do linear
finite element method.
Then any combination
of these linear guys
is going to be piecewise linear,
there's going to be a mesh.
You know the set-up.
It might look like that,
and have a value there.
It might have a value
there, might have a value
there, there, there, and there.
OK.
And let's suppose
this is the winning --
doesn't look like
a winner to me,
because I think it could
probably do better, but --
capital U star.
But remember that
we're measuring --
what's the K norm stuff?
I'm measuring the difference
between these two not
pointwise, which would
be of course pleasant
to say, OK, the distance
is just, you know,
maybe the maximum distance
or the mean square error.
That would be quite pleasant.
But here the measure of
distance involves this K,
which comes with the problem.
So by distance here
I mean the distance
between U star and u star.
Can I write it with a
capital K there to indicate
that that's the K norm?
That's the norm in which this is
small, as small as can be made.
And what is the K norm for
this particular problem?
Well it's the integral,
and involves the c,
and it involves the U star prime
minus the u star prime square
dx, integrated from 0 to 1.
I'm just picking
this example problem
so that you get some idea of
how we're measuring the error.
It's the natural
measure for the error.
It's the energy measure.
We're measuring error in energy.
This is an energy expression.
This thing, you know,
represents some kind
of elastic bar or something,
so we're measuring
the internal energy here.
And notice in particular,
maybe the most important point
is not the c of x, which just
comes along for the ride,
but the fact that our measure of
the error is in the derivative.
We're measuring error
in slopes, because those
are the stresses in
the bar, and that's
where the energy comes from,
internal strain energy.
OK.
So in other words, I have
this function u star,
this curved guy, and I
have this function, which
I'm thinking to be the winner.
And again, it's the
winner in the sense
that it minimizes this.
This is the minimum.
This is the expression that
we have some handle on,
because we know that U
star, capital U star,
will make that as
small as it can.
It does not make small
the pointwise error.
It might try, it
might accidentally --
we hope it does of course --
get pointwise error right.
But what it is constructed
to get right is energy error.
Make that small.
OK.
So now the question is how do
we estimate the difference?
OK.
So now, here's
this key point, how
do we estimate the difference.
Again we're looking
at the error.
By the way, I should have,
maybe I did, put a square there.
That was the norm
squared, but of course,
minimizing the norm -- you
realize why I don't want a big
square root sign,
it's just clumsy.
So I'm looking at
the square there.
OK.
So now, how do you
estimate that thing?
How do you estimate
the thing, knowing
that this piecewise linear, that
came out of some finite element
calculation or some giant
code, is best possible?
Well here's the idea.
Look at a convenient candidate
that might not be the winner.
Let me put, because this
was as small as possible,
this is less than or
equal to U minus u star --
always in the correct measure
-- for every trial function U.
This just says what I've
said now three ways,
that U star's the
best in the K norm.
Now I -- to get some bound
on this, I can take any U,
I can take any U and estimate
its difference from U star,
and that will give me a bound.
In other words, I don't know
what this particular guy
happened to be.
Let me just jump
to the key idea.
I know that that one is
better than the one --
and if I had a
different color --
maybe this thing has
got another color.
Okay, here's another color.
I know it's better
than, for example --
I'm just going to pick one
piecewise linear trial function
that's quite convenient.
Pick the one that
interpolates the exact one.
OK.
Now for some reason, known
only to finite elements,
that wasn't the
finite element winner.
That wasn't U star, that was
another U. For example --
so like, I'll put it in
blue here -- for example,
take U to be the function
that interpolates u star,
little u star, the function
that I've drawn here.
Since our question is how close
can we get to the curved guy
by piecewise linear,
well, one choice
is how close does
the interpolate come.
It doesn't necessarily
come the closest.
Probably not.
But it's in the right ballpark.
So now I just ask
the question, and let
me draw the same picture again.
I have a function
and I interpolate it
by piecewise linear guys.
So piecewise linear
function there.
And so this is a comparison
between the u star
and its interpolate, which
is my candidate U that I'm
recommending as a trial.
And now it's a pure
approximation question.
You see, we no longer have to
know all about finite elements,
we don't have to know anything
about finite elements.
We're just asking the question:
if you give me a function,
and you compare it with the
piecewise linear interpolate,
how far apart are they?
How far apart?
And let me call the step
size h, and of course,
could be unequal steps.
It could be unstructured mesh.
Everything works here.
Now we come to just a basic sort
of understanding of calculus.
How close does a curve
come from the chord?
Really, that's what
it's come down to.
How close is a curved
function from a chord?
I can even blow that up.
So here I have some
curve going up,
and compare that with the chord.
And this distance here is h.
Anybody know?
So I'm just looking
for something like,
is the difference of order
h, is it of order h square,
is it of order e to the h.
What the distance
between the two?
And you could imagine it's a
parabola, because I'm focusing
down on just a little piece.
I take a little parabola,
a little h piece of it,
and I compare it
with a chord, what's
the distance between the two?
That distance there.
Well your eye probably tells
you that it's smaller than h,
because h was this
big, and I'm only
looking this big vertically.
So this distance, that distance
there, maximum distance,
is of order h square.
But that's not the question.
The question is how
far apart are these,
how far apart of the
these in this measure?
How far apart are the slopes?
Because the K norm is dealing
with the slopes, and not
the function itself.
So more important than the
distance is the error in slope,
and would you want to
guess what that's like?
What's your guess on that,
the error in the slope?
Now the slopes are not going
to be as good as the function,
as always.
Slopes are one derivative
higher, you lose something,
you get order h.
So that's the error.
Let's see, I hope
I'm right here.
Yeah.
I think that's right.
There I was speaking
pointwise, and then I've
got to integrate it
over the whole interval
here, a unit interval.
So if I square it, of course,
I'm going to get h square,
and then if I integrated
it, I still have h square,
and then when I take the
square root, I have h.
So h is the right quantity.
If I can put down here what our
conclusion was from this method
by taking capital U to
be this convenient --
not the only choice,
but a convenient choice,
just to get an idea
what the error might be.
And then the error
from the actual U star
is got to be
better, our estimate
is order of h for this
particular application.
This particular application.
That's the error in
energy norm in the slopes.
So the theory of finite
elements would go ahead
to try to show that the error
in the distance between them,
in the displacement you
could say, is h square.
But that's not so easy, and I
won't be able to do it here.
Why is it not easy to say that
the error in the displacement
is of order h square?
It's certainly true for
this interpolate, right.
There's no question that the
interpolate you could easily
see is h square, order h
square away from the function.
But the point is that
capital U star was not
the best in staying
near the function,
it was only the best in
staying near the slope.
So I don't have this
crutch to lean on here.
This is in the K norm, and
not in the mean square norm.
It's in a norm that
deals with slope, but not
with just plain
displacement distance.
OK.
Maybe that's made the point.
And this is the part of finite
element theory just to do that.
OK.
If I could take a
minute about notation,
because the notation that
I've used here of a K
is really a matrix notation.
You don't truly see it
in finite element papers.
For me, it's clear, right?
I mean that identity
was quite clear
from vectors and matrices.
But with finite elements I'm
really dealing with functions.
So it's not fair to use
matrix notation, you know,
when it's integrals, and
derivatives, and functions
that are involve here.
You know, these are functions,
and the actual solution
is a function.
So I all I want to do is mention
the notation that you now see,
say in 16.920, the engineering
course that would be, you know,
quite related to this one of
finite elements and Galerkin
and all sorts of stuff, that
we'll touch in the remaining
weeks.
How would they write the
minimization problem?
The original problem now, going
back to the original problem,
and just saying, wait a
minute, we didn't really
have a good notation for it.
The thing I'm looking for is
a notation -- it's like this.
This is the kind of thing that I
want, c of x u prime square dx.
Well, it might also
have a first-order term
a d of x, u square of
x, it could have that.
It could have
second derivatives.
It could be in two variables.
For Laplace we had minimum of
du/dx squared and du/dx squared
dxdy, well and we had
the linear term too.
I've just written sort
of the left-hand side,
the quadratic term.
And all I want to say is that
everybody, well not everybody,
but a lot of people now,
would use the notation
a of u, u for the
quadratic term.
So that a of u, u,
in an engineering
paper represents the
internal strain energy,
whether it's this, whether
it's this, a combination.
It somehow suggest
to us it's quadratic.
And there's a linear term, and
that's often written l of u.
So I better put down
what l of u typically is.
This l of u might be the
integral of f of x u of x dx.
That would be the linear term.
And I think I'd be happier
to have the 1/2 there.
So that -- really, it's
just a match with this,
but somehow it's
a little cooler.
This looks so much like
vectors and matrices,
that that and that
is kind of neutral.
OK.
So I'm just speaking
about notation here,
and I could've
mentioned this last time
when I was speaking about all
these examples from calculus
of variations.
OK.
So that's the minimum problem.
If you give me that notation
for the minimum problem,
what's the weak form
in this notation?
So I'm introducing this just
because you see it elsewhere.
It's it's exactly what
we're doing all the time,
so I just want you
to recognize it.
OK.
So how do we get the weak form?
Can I recap how you
get the weak form?
If u is the winner.
Right.
I'll just think of
u as the winner.
Then if I move it by
v, move it a little,
then this expression
should go up.
So what happens
if I move it by v?
So I'm going to compare the two.
I'm going to compare that with
1/2 a of u plus v, you know,
upped a little,
minus l of u plus v.
And the point is that
this guy should be --
maybe I'll erase min and
put in less or equal to.
I'm just recapping
that this should
be less or equal to
this one for all v. You
see it's the weak stuff?
u is the winner.
I'm now using u and
not u star, and I'm
using v for the delta
u, for the movement
away from the winner,
which raises the energy.
OK.
Now what do I plan to do?
I plan to cancel common terms
here, and see what's going on,
and find that first variation.
Just what I did last time.
I'm just doing it in
this new notation.
So what's the point?
This l of u is linear.
So l of u plus v is the same
as l of u and l of v, right.
If I put in u plus
v there, it splits
into two integrals here they
are, so when I subtract,
these guys go.
Now, what about this one?
Well, just as last time
when I put in u plus v
here and expanded everything,
now I have something squared.
So this business here
is going to be 1/2.
I'll get something
from the u alone.
And then I'll get two something,
canceling the 1/2, from u
and v, that's the cross term.
And then I'll get
something from the v alone.
I'm dodging a couple of
bullets here just going
to the main point.
OK.
So the main point is
I'm going to subtract,
I'm going to at the differences.
So the zero-order
terms are all gone,
and it's this quantity that
has to be greater or equal 0,
right -- because I was left with
that greater or equal sign --
for all v. OK.
Don't let me leave
minus l of v there.
OK.
So that's the thing that has
to be greater or equal to 0.
Now we're just going to repeat
the same the discussion that we
had last time with
different letters.
If this is going to be
greater or equal 0 for all v,
then I'm going to think of
small v's, in which case
this term is going to be smaller
than the others and won't help.
So what has to happen?
What has to happen for this
to be greater equal to 0
for all v?
You know like we're
taking the derivative
in the direction of v. We're
moving in the direction of v.
And this is the
first-order term,
that's the first variation.
That's what has to
be 0 for all of v.
I guess I can bring it over
here if you eye will follow it.
I have a of u, v
minus l of v, that's
the sort of first-order term,
and then the second-order term.
Has to be greater
or equal 0, all v.
And the question is so what?
What do we get out of that?
Well what I'm
saying is this stuff
has to be 0, because v
could have either sign.
So if this was
positive or negative,
I could switch
sign if I want to.
So it has to be 0.
So a of u, v has to equal l of
v, and that's the weak form.
That's the weak form, that's
the form integral of c u prime v
prime dx equals
integral of f*v*dx.
That's the l of v, and
this is the a of u and v.
This is what you see
in engineering papers,
when they're launching into
the finite element method,
and they're planning
to get some notation.
That's a very familiar notation.
And then the final point
is what about this term?
So now we know this is 0.
This is the weak form
of the equation, find u,
so that this holds
for all v. That's
the weak form of the equation.
Oh yeah, I better
not rush by it.
This is the form in
which you plug in --
this is the form finite
elements come from.
It doesn't solve this
equation exactly.
This is the
differential equation.
I'm in here.
It's our Euler-Lagrange
equation.
The finite element method says,
OK, take the trial functions,
and get it right for those guys.
So that give us our
N equations, where
this is a continuous problem.
Yeah.
So this is what
just leads you --
the weak form is what leads you
naturally to finite elements.
You take this, and
you only make it
true on a finite
dimensional space.
OK.
And the final comment
is what about this guy?
Well the whole point is that
we assume positive definite,
we assume stability,
we've made our life easy
by guaranteeing by the fact that
this is always greater equal 0.
I don't even have to
think about this one.
OK.
Because if u and v
are the same, this
is a square, and that
material coefficient that
better be not negative, right.
OK.
Thank you for your
patience to listen to that.
See this notation
for the same thing
that we did last time
for the weak form,
and you see how it pays
off immediately to give us
the finite element form.
OK.
Good.
So the project
ones are all there,
and there's just two
or three left here.
And I hope you have
a super weekend,
and do give a thought
to project two.